you're sounding an awful lot
parallel the conversation is moving in a
similar direction to 100 Sam Harris
recently I would think it's very
different but happy to hear more
he identified on an episode that I did
with him not long ago
the fact that we have lost trust in our
institutions and yet abandoning them is
also wholesale is is also not an option
Sam also tried
to say I can see the problems on the I
say them can see the problems on the
right and I can see the problems on the
left and there is a group of people
who have allowed their irritation with
the left
to color their thinking to the point
that they now are in a right-wing
situation without understanding the
dangers on the right
I think Sam is discounting the idea that
once people wake up to the ID to the
concept that they were living in an
orchestrated Truman Show
that they did not understand
they're not going to have the idea of
like oh sure the vaccines were a little
bit more dangerous than claimed and
maybe a little bit less effective and
maybe we knew a little bit more about
the lab League no way
you spat directly in my face and told me
not only that it was raining but that I
was a crazy person for thinking that you
spat directly in my face and you piled
up how many Nobel laureates to defend
uh the idea that any inquiry into the
origin of this virus was racism
it's like you're dead to me
and I think that that's what people are
not understanding in the Democratic
party on
increasingly the basic attitude is
whoever this class of people is that
crawled into our Elite institutions is
just dead
like there's nothing Anthony fauci could
say at this moment that I want to hear
it's not that I don't think that he
doesn't know virology or epidemiology
I know I can't trust him because of the
way in which he looked into my eyes
and then you know when Stephen Colbert
is Dancing with syringes singing the
vaccine song
and Ariana Grande you know is in a super
highly produced number from like
Hairspray but converted to vaccines
uh with a giant picture of Anthony fauci
and everybody's celebrating like it's a
May Day celebration
um I get it I live in a completely fake
world and I wrote an article about this
in 2011 on kfabe which is the system of
lies that undergirds professional
wrestling so now you're you've woken up
to the idea that you've spent your life
watching something like major league
baseball or Premier League soccer
whatever it is
and it's all fake
and now you don't know who you are you
don't know who your country is you don't
know what a Ballot Box is you have no
idea what news is or media you don't
know what a university is actually
teaching
you've got people running around who are
calling themselves Scholars who publish
in scholarly journals and sit in
scholarly seats and you can tell what
they're saying is completely wrong and
it's directly in their area of expertise
so the thing about patent matching that
I said was
there are still many people who are
Scholars who are in positions of
authority inside of highfaluting
institutions
the presumably do want to do good and do
want to deploy their skills in a way
that does this
is it a case that every single
institution is completely wrong or
is this reflexive
skepticism yeah
being tuned up too highly to the point
where there is skepticism about things
that don't deserve it and how do we
determine between the two okay so we
have to talk about the institutions that
are fighting back Twitter which has
become X is not on the same standard
that the uh Facebooks are or Google is
Elon is doing something different we can
talk about what
the University of Chicago is still
fighting
uh my daughter just graduated from the
University of Chicago I never mentioned
where she was while she was there
um
it is it needs it needs support
we have to support the schools that
fought back for example I believe Ohio
State fought back and there's a school
in Oklahoma that fought back
and leading that charge is the
University of Chicago we have
organizations like fire
uh that promote Free Speech uh we have
professors who are taking on some risk
like Jonathan height but we're not
seeing the gnome Chomsky effect where
you do amazing research and they have to
put up with every crazy idea that comes
through your mind
right
that's important
look up a person named Serge Lang in
mathematics and something called the
file to understand how dangerous it is
to screw with real Scholars what happens
give us the 30 000 foot View
you know they put people tried to put
like say Sam Huntington into the
National Academy of Sciences it was an
architect of the Vietnam War and sirs
Lang just said I looked through his
papers I find the following mathematical
statements this is not science why is
this person in the academy and then they
fight back
and I fought back with Sarah slang when
he was at Harvard
where we tried to engage Sam Huntington
on on that topic you can't have these
dangerous people running around that's
why all of us are discredited maybe you
haven't noticed this
but like Jordan Peterson is discredited
Sam Harris as discredited Joe Rogan is
discredited Brett Weinstein as
discredited Ben Shapiro is discredited
Barry Weiss is discredited everybody
is discredited Tim Paul referred to it
as the idw's Walking Corpse phase at the
moment well
my point is this personal destruction is
the coin of the realm and some of the
personal destruction that you see that
looks organic is is orchestrated as well
and we're just in this thing where in my
opinion what you're looking at is
something called deconfliction but
people don't know what that is
deconfliction is supposed to stop what
are called Blue on Blue incidences so
Blue on Blue incidences you have two
branches of government that don't know
that they're operating covertly so maybe
you have an investigative team and an
undercover team and the investigative
team is about to blow the cover thinking
that they've got a Target but it's
actually an undercover agent so what
they're supposed to do is they're
supposed to check in with these
centralized systems and say do you have
any assets in this Arena we're about to
move yes we do oh okay so
they find out and this is supposed to
stop Blue on Blue
the interesting thing is even though
there are three systems called Safety
Net RIS safe and case Explorer you can't
use them unless you are an official part
of the government
so I called up one of them had a half an
hour conversation before I started
asking about Jeffrey Epstein and then
they immediately said this call will be
terminated in five seconds
uh for maybe it was cases case Explorer
for South Florida something like that
what happens when you have a civilian
that's not signed up
for non-disclosure under no rules you're
an American citizen with full right to
free speech and you stumble on something
that you're not supposed to know about
that is a deconfliction problem that
nobody has ever solved so the first
thing I'd like to throw at is if we have
three separate systems to keep like the
intelligence community and local police
departments from tripping over each
other
what do you think we do
when ordinary citizens get wind of
something amiss that some super secret
operation
and my claim is we discredit them
we pre-bunk them in the language of the
gec I believe
you see
we're all familiar we're all familiar
with debunking
misinformation and disinformation you've
got some disinformation that's spread it
around we debunk it by giving you the
truth what happens when somebody is
spreading the truth in a way that is
unhelpful
to a statecraft level narrative
well we didn't know what the words were
but we just found out and it's you
pre-bunk the Mal information
now if you didn't grow up knowing what
Mal information is here's a
quick refresher malinformation is actual
information
but it's harmful
right the equivalent of Politically
Incorrect Incarnation well or you know
you're trying to make sure that uh
there's support for the war in Ukraine
and somebody actually realizes that
things are much more desperate than than
they thought well that would be
deleterious to our our efforts if the
objective is to get potent to capitulate
so now you have to pre-bunk
the Mal information which means destroy
the reputation
of the person spreading the information
that's countering the official
disinformation and misinformation
so I can't work out why anybody's
confused and why they're having trouble
existing in the stay in school kids
um
the point is I've got all of these
friends who are pre-bunked malinformers
that's what a club what a club that's
what I do
I'm a pre-bunked malinformant
there's never been a sexier title I
spread malinformation yeah and I need to
be pre-bunked so of course I'm going to
be a grifter
I'm going to be I don't know Charlotte
and I'm gonna well he's over
can we stop trying to make Eric
Weinstein a thing blah blah blah and
there's a you know giant Farms of of
people and Bots that are dedicated to
spreading bad feelings about anybody
who's gonna contradict narrative well
don't forget as well that
the coordination doesn't necessarily
need to be there because the incentives
align online
there's an emergent part there's a
non-emergent part correct I will not
agree with anyone who tells me it's all
one or the or all the other but part of
this is actually coordinated yeah
so close that loop on the
agentic sovereign individual existing in
the world
holy [__] I'm getting bukakied with this
total awfulness of of information here
bukaki just means splattered in Japanese
that's why it's not a terrible term to
use absolutely thank you it's actually
been appropriated by the adult industry
in a way that I think the Japanese
should reclaim actually Melissa Chen has
probably done more to popularize this in
intellectual circles than anyone else so
shout out to Miss Melissa Chad Melissa
Chen and bukaki in the same sentence
something that we weren't expecting
today she uh I think there was a period
of her life where she would use it in
every public appearance just sneak it in
right okay the [__] of the gaps
so anyway you have a situation where
nobody knows what's going on and I don't
think Sam is comfortable by the way
being here like you're in open water and
you have all of these instructions about
what to do when you're swimming near
land which is you know try to align
yourself with the shore don't fight the
current and like that's not where you
are you're just in Open Water
and you're treading water and you don't
know whether they're oceanic white tips
around and you don't know whether you
can keep this up for much longer but
there is no land
there's a big difference with Sam
go a little deeper make that a little
plainer for me
you cannot trust Harvard
or nature
you cannot trust the Office of
Management and budget all the Lancet or
the Lancet or the Bureau of Labor
Statistics
you cannot trust
any newspaper that I'm aware of you
cannot trust the CDC or the NIH
or The Who
now
people will hear that and they'll say oh
my God Eric you're spreading distrust
and fear it's like I'm a pastor shoot
the messenger all you want
all of those institutions are out of
control and we all know it
and entirely out of control no mostly I
did this on trigonometry we have this
anti-institutional point how is it that
the airlines can't keep my seat clean
uh and can't make sure that I'm able to
recline it properly or that the Wi-Fi
doesn't go out and then their planes
never crash
so the institutions are functioning and
not functioning they're lying and
telling the truth they're getting it
done and failing outright over and over
again
and it's it's even worse because if if
the planes crashed all the time then
you'd say okay well these people are
incompetent
but it's like the selective
incompetence and Madness and
what I think is is that Sam wanted to
treat this as look it's pretty annoying
what's going on on the left and it's
pretty annoying what's going on with the
institutions but let's not let's not
lose sight of the fact
January 6th
people don't feel that way people feel
like wait a minute I don't know which
end is up I don't know who's telling me
the truth anymore I can spot these lies
that are so transparent and this is the
theory of Lies as a checksum
so when you get a binary for a computer
program that you want to install on your
computer you want to know well is this
what came from Microsoft or did somebody
adulterate it and when I click on this
thing it's going to install ransomware
on on my machine so there's something
called a checksum
which is generated by how the program
was compiled
and it would be almost impossible to
come up with a second program that would
generate the same checksum verification
yeah
if the check sum is off I don't install
the thing and the checksums are all off
and that's why people are going crazy
and that's why to your earlier point
isn't it interesting that we're not
talking about the level of uncertainty
right like this is not sustainable so
Sam is 100 correct on a lot of things
that people are making fun of him for
and I assume that I will be uh Keel
hauled all over Twitter for saying this
you cannot have a world without
institutions we're not built for it
we're just there's no part of you that
is prepared to generate all your own
electricity and and you know kill all
your own game and
get your own clean water and it's
you need an army
you need a police department you can
only play
um Frontier you know Wild West so long
before you realize that Modern Life
can't be supported this one
and we can't go with the institutions we
have
so we need institutions we can't go with
these institutions not because the
institutions are wrong but because the
inhabitants are wrong to a person
they've been selected for by this
ability to lie because growth evaporated
that's one of my main riffs we don't
have to go into it but basically that in
the absence of real growth everything
turns pathological
and so it's just heartbreaking to see
some of these people saying look we've
always known that the institutions were
wrong we finally have the ability to
prove that let's tear them all down so
that's a very popular perspective at the
moment other people want to claim let's
cling to the institutions because we
know we need them and we'll look past
the fact that they're obviously lying
about almost everything of importance
that's not really tenable we can't vote
these people out because like Dianne
Feinstein could beat me easily in a run
uh you know for for Senate I don't know
why because the machine
is stronger than actually the the vision
we had for democracy so we've got you
know Mitch McConnell having a
temporary you know ischemic attack on
camera we've got somebody post-stroke in
Pennsylvania
uh having defeated Mehmet Oz we've got
Dianne Feinstein we've got
um Nancy Pelosi trading up a storm we
can't get rid of any of these people Joe
Biden is way too old for this job and
has been in government since he was 29
in 1972 when he won his senate seat
this is a joke it's beyond Preposterous
and by the way it comes out of not
loving your children
what's up
people who love their children don't
drill holes in their children's life
raft
in the Modern World post-world War II
was a life raft to get us to the next
stage and the number of
older people I see liquidating
everything
so that they can live out their final
days in the same style to which they've
become accustomed is impossible in a
world where people love their children
in other Muse this episode is brought to
you by Shopify Shopify is the e-commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're a
garage entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify
is the only tool you need to start run
and grow your business without any
expertise Shopify puts you in control of
every sales channel so whether you're
selling satin sheets from shopify's
in-person POS or offering organic olive
oil on shopify's e-commerce platform
they have got everything covered for you
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce
across the United States massive Brands
like gymshark still use Shopify that's
how powerful it is so if you want to
start selling something anything online
Shopify is where to start you can begin
a one dollar per month trial period
right now by going to the link in the
show notes below or heading to
shopify.com
modern wisdom that's shopify.com modern
wisdom to take your business to the next
level today thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Eric then press here for the full length
three hour episode
go on
press it